Trascrizione: Veronica Bresciani
Revisore: Maria Pia Lanfranchi
[Musica]
Allora, iniziamo con un piccolo
aneddoto personale
che ho riportato in uno dei miei libri,
ma che è molto importante nella storia
di cui stiamo parlando.
Io avevo 29 anni, lavoravo in azienda,
facevo l’impiegato e il freelance,
che era il nome carino
che negli anni 80 si dava ai precari,
perché negli anni 80
ci davamo tutti abbastanza un tono,
poi ero diventato impiegato,
dopo impiegato più specializzato, quadro
e addirittura, a 29 anni,
sono diventato dirigente.
Mi ero prefissato di arrivarci a 30,
quindi ricordo il giorno
in cui, tornando dalla stanza
dell'amministratore delegato
con in mano questa lettera,
ho percorso il corridoio,
sono entrato nella mia stanza,
mi sono seduto e ho riletto questa lettera
di cui conoscevo naturalmente
il contenuto, che mi nominava dirigente.
E ho un ricordo preciso
della sensazione che provai.
Non era affatto una sensazione univoca,
era una sensazione meticcia;
da un lato ero ovviamente soddisfatto:
mio padre aveva fatto
un percorso aziendale analogo, quindi
mi rispecchiavo nella sua carriera
ed ero molto soddisfatto
di essere riuscito nell'intento
che mi ero prefissato.
Ma, naturalmente, il non trovarmi
in una condizione
di perfetta sintonia,
di perfetto benessere,
mi ha subito insospettito.
Avrei dovuto, come tutti quelli
che sono pienamente nel luogo
dove devono essere e
fanno quello che si sentono di dover fare,
avrei dovuto compiacermi con me stesso,
provare un grande piacere
e l'istante dopo
fissare nuovamente un nuovo obiettivo.
Così fanno gli ambiziosi
ed io ero un ambizioso,
ero uno che voleva crescere,
voleva imparare,
voleva fare strada.
Ho provato una sensazione molto forte,
molto chiara, che lì per lì
non sono riuscito a decodificare ma
che poi, col tempo, ho capito essere
la certezza che non avrei fatto quello
tutta la vita.
Nel momento in cui dovevo
settare nuovamente l'asticella,
ho pensato che quello sport
non era una cosa che avrei fatto
per tutto il tempo.
Questa sensazione si è,
diciamo così, radicata
nella mia mente, nel mio cuore.
Io ho continuato a fare il mio lavoro
con molto impegno, molta partecipazione
le cose sono andate bene,
sono stato fortunato,
ho fatto buone cose.
Era un periodo in cui io lavoravo
nel mondo della comunicazione
e le cose andavano bene,
sono stato bravo,
mi sono impegnato,
sono stato anche molto fortunato,
ho avuto buoni maestri.
Però le cose, in un certo senso,
sono rimaste lì appese:
quella sensazione è rimasta dentro di me.
C'è un altro aneddoto
che in qualche modo chiude il cerchio
tra due sensazioni
che si sono richiamate tra loro
e hanno determinato un'azione:
è stato molti anni dopo,
ero sul raccordo anulare di Roma,
vivevo a Roma all'epoca,
erano le sette e mezza di mattina,
eravamo già chiusi tutti dentro
la loro macchinetta,
ognuno con i telefonini accesi,
faceva già molto caldo,
era il 4 luglio per curiosa coincidenza,
quel giorno mi sono detto: così non va,
non posso vivere tutta la vita così,
non posso uscire quando tutti escono,
non posso tornare quando tutti tornano,
non posso fare le cose che fanno tutti,
non voglio vivere secondo schemi
che sono stati fissati da qualcun altro,
o che sono il risultato di una norma
che si è affermata come la prioritaria,
la vincente,
quella omologazione:
essere tutti nella stessa circostanza,
mi è sembrato insopportabile.
Allora sono uscito dall'autostrada
appena ho potuto,
dal raccordo anulare,
che è una specie di autostrada,
e ho cercato per le vie
di un posto che non conoscevo,
perché era una zona di Roma
dove non uscivo mai,
ho cercato un bar
che avesse una pergola possibilmente,
potendo stare fuori all'ombra,
ho preso un caffè,
mi sono seduto al tavolino
con l'idea di studiare una soluzione
che non avevo però:
io sapevo fare, e ci voleva tutta
che lo sapessi fare,
solo quello che facevo.
Non avevo un piano B,
non avevo una soluzione,
non avevo pensato ad altro
e ricordo che, quel giorno, ho preso
un pezzo di carta e una penna,
mi sono messo a ragionare
e mi sono messo a fare la SWAT analysis,
tutti i manager presenti sanno cos'è:
quella roba per cui tu fai
una serie di colonne,
metti quello che hai, quello che
non hai, quello che ti serve
quello che dovresti avere
per fare quello che vorresti fare.
La colonna delle cose che mi servivano
era molto ricca,
quelle che avevo erano poche,
erano buone per fare
quello che avevo sempre fatto
ma non oltre, e da quel momento
ho iniziato a lavorare,
ho iniziato a lavorare a un progetto
che era un progetto di liberazione,
diciamo così,
di autenticità,
di autenticazione.
Io ero nato per scrivere e navigare.
Ognuno di noi è nato per fare una cosa
e tante persone mi scrivono:
tu sei fortunato,
perché tu sai navigare,
sai scrivere,
come se io fossi nato
col timone in mano,
con la penna in mano, ma insomma,
come potete immaginare non è così,
io non so fare niente.
Questo ovviamente non è vero.
Jack London diceva una cosa molto bella,
scriveva che ognuno di noi è
come una pallina su un piano sfalsato:
se noi lasciamo quella pallina,
compie una traiettoria
Che se non le rompi l'anima lungo la via,
è una certa traiettoria.
lui chiamava questa
la linea di minore resistenza,
cioè quello che noi faremmo bene,
sentendoci bene mentre lo facciamo,
se potessimo farlo.
La mia linea di minore resistenza,
in questo sono stato fortunato,
mi era abbastanza chiara;
cioè io, fin da quando ero un bambino,
sapevo che... sentivo, perché poi sapere
è una questione
che viene con la consapevolezza,
ma sentivo che dovevo
scrivere e navigare,
quella era la mia linea
di minore resistenza.
In quel momento si compie,
nella mia vita,
un fatto molto importante
dal sapere che cosa fosse
il "libero da",
che è una cosa molto diffusa,
ognuno di noi sa
cosa vuol dire "libero da":
libero dal capufficio,
libero dai ritmi,
libero dalle incombenze,
dalle responsabilità,
dal peso sul cuore,
dai mutui,
dalle relazioni coatte,
non scelte da te,
ma da un direttore del personale,
che, per definizione, è un pazzo,
come sappiamo, se ti ha messo
accanto di scrivania
uno come il tuo collega,
da quella consapevolezza
molto diffusa io acquisivo
un'altra consapevolezza,
che è quella di che cosa
dovevo diventare "libero di",
che fa parte però
dell'altra metà della faccenda
la gran parte della gente
quando parla di libertà
ha chiaro cosa vuol dire "libero da",
non cosa lui vorrebbe, dovrebbe, sente
che vorrebbe essere "libero di".
Ho lasciato il lavoro,
da allora ho cambiato la mia vita,
l'ho cambiata facendo un progetto
intorno a questo.
Essendo uno scrittore,
essendolo sempre stato,
ed essendolo poi divenuto
in maniera più professionale,
più metodologica, un progetto
che ha a che fare
con un altro modo per vivere,
perché ho scoperto dopo tante paure,
dal primo esempio che vi ho fatto
dei 29 anni,
a quando ho cambiato la mia vita
ne sono passati 12,
perché ho dovuto vincere
tutte le paure del caso,
ho dovuto pormi tutte le domande
e trovare una risposta originale:
all'epoca di queste cose non si parlava,
era il 2008 quando cambiai la mia vita,
il gennaio del 2008 per coincidenza,
per settembre la crisi di Lehman Brothers
mi provò, a dispetto di ogni dubbio,
che avevo fatto bene.
Da quel momento in avanti
il progetto si è arricchito
ed è diventato una cosa
che io potevo avere il coraggio,
finalmente, di tentare di vivere.
Ero terrorizzato, naturalmente,
di non avere lo stipendio.
Sono anche il figlio
di una stirpe di genovesi,
quindi la faccenda è anche seria,
ma soprattutto ero terrorizzato
di interrompere una carriera:
ero arrivato in una buona posizione,
per me per i miei mezzi,
e sapevo che dai 40 anni in poi
avrei potuto raccogliere
tutto quello che avevo seminato;
Si chiamano Relazioni Pubbliche:
ci vuole parecchio per costruirle
queste relazioni, però dopo producono
i loro frutti: facevo comunicazione,
relazioni pubbliche, eccetera.
Tutto quello che sarebbe venuto dopo
io non lo avrei vissuto,
quindi lo stavo perdendo
la paura di perdere quello che si ha,
mi sono reso conto con il tempo,
era il freno maggiore,
perché non c'era coscienza
di tutto quello che non avrei avuto
se non avessi tentato.
Questa è una cosa molto importante.
Gli anni che sono seguiti
sono stati i più felici della mia vita,
naturalmente, com'è facile immaginare,
perché sono vissuto facendo esattamente
ciò per cui sono nato.
Sono vissuto tentando di essere
ciò che io sapevo di poter essere
e ciò che sapevo di dover tentare.
Naturalmente, per fare questo,
il progetto si è dovuto
articolare bene, in una serie
di cose molto concrete:
dal gennaio del 2008 a oggi
ho speso 74mila euro overall,
quindi ho vissuto con 8.500 euro l'anno,
ma si può fare molto di più:
la media risente dei primi anni
in cui ero poco abituato.
La casa dove vivo,
una casa di pietra, un fienile
della fine del seicento,
suona anche figo
se lo dici a una ragazza,
che però ho ristrutturato tutto da me,
questa è la parte meno figa,
in cui è meglio
non coinvolgere la ragazza.
Chi aveva mai fatto un tetto
di una casa di legno, di pietra,
e poi il tetto di legno,
nessuno naturalmente,
e neanche io,
il che si è tragicamente visto
il primo inverno,
quando avevo 36 vie d'acqua nel tetto.
Ho dormito con la cerata integrale,
meno male che ero attrezzato,
con la goccia sulla spalla
che veniva giù,
avevo dimenticato
di mettere la carta catramata
pensando che la pendenza bastasse.
insomma, di errori ne ho fatti tanti,
ho assolutamente compreso però
che una persona che fa la vita che fa
ognuno di noi ogni giorno,
così complicata, ha tutte le risorse
per mettersi di fronte ai problemi
e tentare di risolverli
in maniera molto creativa, a volte,
in maniera anche un po fallimentare
ma comunque molto soddisfacente.
Ho scoperto che si può auto-produrre
la gran parte delle cose che ci servono:
io mi faccio ammazzare,
piuttosto che comprare qualcosa.
Questo, il fatto di essere
di origine genovese aiuta,
ma non basta bisogna anche
un pò inventarsi le cose.
Aggiusto ogni cosa che che mi serve
di utilizzare o di riutilizzare.
Considero una specie di morte interiore
quando un elettrodomestico
non lo posso aggiustare
e lo devo cambiare.
Però in tutto questo
c'è una grande possibilità.
E' assolutamente possibile
vivere diversamente,
assolutamente possibile,
anzi necessario,
uscire dalla omologazione del pensiero,
uscire dall’omologazione
degli stili di vita.
Abbiamo sentito prima
una cosa molto interessante
di un attivista per i diritti umani,
quella è una questione davvero importante:
aiutare le persone
ad essere più sane,
a vivere di più, eccetera.
Ma c'è qualcosa,
io credo profondamente,
che viene prima di quello.
Quello lo fanno gli eroi,
quello lo fanno le persone speciali;
molti di noi potrebbero farlo certamente,
ma sono sicuro che sia una cosa
veramente oltre l'asticella
per tanti di noi,
ma c'è una cosa che, invece,
tutti noi possiamo fare
ed è quello di contribuire alla società
cercando di vivere in maniera autentica,
cercando di essere davvero
quello che si è nati per essere,
smettendo di fingere nel fare mestieri
che non ci appartengono,
che spesso e volentieri
sono dannosi per la società,
smettendo di avere 29 gradi in casa,
casa mia si riscalda soltanto con la legna
che io spacco, brucio,
se lasci le sigarette sul divano
a fine ottobre
ricomincia a fumare a marzo,
perché chiaramente
non ti puoi allontanare dal camino.
Questo poi tra l'altro contribuisce
all'abbattimento dei costi.
Si possono fare davvero
tantissime cose,
tantissime cose molto semplici,
molto alla nostra portata,
che rendono la nostra vita
terribilmente avventurosa
senza che poi andiamo a vedere
"Into the wild" e ci emozioniamo
per quello che vediamo.
Lo possiamo vivere noi,
anche senza quegli eccessi,
e soprattutto ho iniziato
a fare davvero
quello che sentivo di voler fare,
di poter fare,
che è scrivere e navigare.
Posso essere d'aiuto alla società
con quello che scrivo?
Può la mia ricerca dell'autenticità
determinare qualcosa di valore,
per chi ho intorno,
per chi può leggere
qualcosa di interessante,
per chi può trovare una soluzione
attraverso un esempio,
una testimonianza?
Questa è senz'altro una cosa
che va fatta. Certamente,
quando quello che facciamo,
se lo scriviamo su un foglio,
è troppo diverso,
i segni sono troppo diversi
dai segni che abbiamo addosso,
forse quello che stiamo scrivendo
non è letteratura, ma è solo finzione.
Questa è una cosa che dovremmo ricordarci:
ci vuole una certa consistenza
e una certa identità
tra quello che facciamo
e quello che diciamo,
e spesso non c'è.
Grazie.
[Applauso]